alors fard à fossette pour les plus
jeunes d'entre vous qui nous regardez
madame la connaissez madame alors drôle
de dames et surtout c'était super Jaimie
bah oui c'est vrai elle était mariée
avec le
majorités
donc qui qui aime bien cette vieille
personne
forcément moi je l'ai trouvé alors
c'est ah ouais moi c'était drôle de
dames c'est mon fantasme absolu de
jeunesse mais je crois qu'elle est
encore pas mal parce qu'il y a eu un
petit montage de Facebook
[Applaudissements]
c'est
pour ça qu'elle a pas vieilli finalement
forcément c'est plus difficile
elle est morte en 2009 absolument de la
mort de Michael Jackson et là c'est pour
ça ben voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai
oublié qu'elle était malade merci
beaucoup pour cette belle séquence on va
enchaîner alors alors je suis à peu près
sûr de savoir qui c'est alors il est
d'abord il est très beau j'ai le très
grand je pense que c'est le je pense que
c'est le numéro 1 des acteurs français
aujourd'hui
et je suis sûr que c'est soit madame
Coste soit madame Wespiser c'est où là
Ulule ou l'autre
j'adore je trouve que en plus c'est un
acteur mais tellement intense enfin je
voilà j'adore ce mec je trouve je trouve
sexy quoi est-ce que on parle de
fantasme si vous rencontrez cette
personne
ma femme me dit toujours elle sur votre
absolue c'est par exemple c'est Kean
elle me dit si je le croise et que il me
dit elle a un passe-droit je vais direct
je vais tromper avec c'est sympathique
elle rencontre aussi bah alors
figurez-vous j'ai un truc de fou à vous
dire elle avait vu une voyance qu'il
avait dit tu vas rencontrer l'homme de
ta vie et elle apprend que Keanu Reeves
est apparu pour une interview donc elle
se débrouille pour faire l'interview
avec Keanu Reeves en disant ça y est il
est à Paris je vais lui faire interview
paf ça va bien se passer et en fait
c'est moi qu'elle a rencontré non
en fait quand elle a fait une interview
elle a fait elle a joué acte 2 scène 3
comme ça voilà un peu habillé comme
soficos par exemple et il ne l'a pas
regardé du tout rien tiens c'est la
mienne
alors on y va
alors
on vous demande de votre part
je vous rappelle que la question se pose
pas comme ça d'accord très bien bon en
même temps
c'est incroyable là-bas ah non mais
c'est vrai au début de TPMP on était
tous moches de toute façon alors
c'est vous qui dit ben moi je n'ai rien
dit
pas là au début donc je n'ai pas là mais
moi je me trouvais beau depuis le début
et vous la coquine là
je voulais repérer
alors sandales dessous
chantal Ladesou
ça se voit
dormir dans mon couple excuse-moi
alors qui qui hésite entre le prince
Harry et et mort aussi Isabelle
[Musique]
il me plairait bien physiquement
elle m'adore elle est très belle
bien sûr
c'est pas moi accélérer
c'est Bernard alors vous êtes pas du
tout son type hein ça je vous le dis
c'est je l'adore je l'ai reçu très dans
la crise elle est sympa marrante avec sa
copine Géraldine natacha est
intelligente elle est jolie elle est
bien
ah alors Béatrice vous êtes plutôt vous
êtes le fantasme de quelqu'un je pensais
pas que ça allait s'afficher dans la
Grande Guerre
[Applaudissements]
puis actrice américaine
voilà quoi tout va bien
alors je vous le dis non
j'ai pu partager un moment avec Béatrice
un jour je l'ai ramené en scooter on
était tous les deux
alors le dalaï-lama ça c'est déjà de
spirituel
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est vous non moi c'était Delphine
parce que j'adorais essayer l'amour
tantrique alors pour entrer
vous êtes en face de quelqu'un et vous
faites l'amour sans vous toucher
dans une chambre l'un en face de l'autre
et en fait vous vous regardez juste dans
les yeux et vous pouvez juste peut-être
vous toucher comme ça c'est pas
forcément sexuel et après vous arrivez à
avoir un orgasme encore plus puissant
parce que vous êtes en connexion ultime
avec la personne
madame ça vous intéresse c'est l'amour
parfait
[Applaudissements]
autrefois et alors moi déjà qui aiment
pas les préliminaires mais alors ça dans
la famille chien
c'est fini
[Musique]
si j'étais une femme c'est vous
avez rencontré et j'avais un crush sur
lui et c'était malheureusement j'ai été
invité à sa fête de fiançailles quand il
s'est marié avec une actrice qui
s'appelait Jennifer Esposito et
j'étais allée à sa fête de fiançailles
j'étais un peu dégoûtée
c'était pas possible
et vous quand il est votre votre
fantasme
alors c'est un petit peu délicat parce
que j'ai mon nom dans le public
[Rires]
c'est pas la meilleure photo elle doit
être gratuite
il me dit
[Applaudissements]